make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we're picking back up again with
Batman versus not really Batman versus
Superman Batman Superman essentially
like the Batman who lasts now this is
awesome right because in the last video
we picked up with with Jaime Reyes
basically being infected and then using
the Blue Beetle scarab to essentially
infect a fortress of solitude right and
so what this does is follow up
immediately after that now for the most
part taking over the entire defense
system of the fortress of solitude and
using it against most both Batman and
Superman for the most part let Superman
understanding how it works
initially he would begin to find a way
out right like that was kind of the
expectation is that he would find a way
out ah Batman will be a little more
stuck right because he doesn't really
know the fortress inside and out the way
the Superman does but of course given
his ingenuity he would ultimately find a
way out as well and so really if it's
just Jaime Reyes facing off against
Batman versus a Batman of Superman
eventually they would be able to
overtake it right just by sheer force of
will or or what-have-you but notice this
the Batman who lost knowing what he
knows about Superman right and knowing
the Superman would keep an eye on him
and you know not really literally
insofar as listening to him and making
sure that he's not really making an
escape or something like that the Batman
who laughs uses this to his advantage
and just starts whispering in the ear of
Superman the funny thing about this is
that what you end up getting here is the
intervention of Donna Troy and Hawkman
but not in the way that you expect
instead they're siding with the Batman
who last and this is a crazy thing
because it's it's it's it's interesting
in this scenario because it's best we
could tell this is actually Donna Troy
from the main DC Universe right and the
reason why is because what she says of
course kind of lashing out of Superman
saying for everything you've done right
this is for Wally this is for dick this
is for Roy this is heroes in crisis
stuff and this is one of the reasons why
stories like that real why we covered
that I cover those events is because
it's one of those kind of stories where
yes it could be read in isolation but
also because it would be referenced with
regards to things that go on in the
future and that's exactly what's
happening here no one really knows what
was going on with Wally West when it
comes to Dick Grayson he was shot in the
head by KGB stright recovered the story
of Batman fighting KGB so the reason why
that happened but Dick Grayson changes
name to Rick and he's basically trying
to live a normal life and ultimately
suffered like brain damage and like
memory loss and things like that
so he's essentially out and Roy Harper
died during heroes in crisis and so
because of the various escapades and
because of the various actions of Batman
and Superman over the years what are
they intended to do good things or not
it's resulted in casualties and one of
the things that Donna Troy hits on here
is
the the rule they play right Superman
being this this figure of Hope and
Batman being this Dark Knight that while
they are inspiring in their own way they
inspire people who are essentially
ill-equipped to become superheroes to
join their cause and then March off to
their dooms right but but we'll talk
more about Hardman here in a second
because what seems to be going on with
him it's not actually what's going on
with him and it's actually a really cool
reference that Joshua Winston is pulling
out here but again like what we end up
learning here with Commissioner Gordon
really sort of you know speaking to
these guys is that everything that's
been going on here is simply one piece
of a much bigger puzzle and we didn't
really know what that puzzle was until
just now that what he basically says is
like you know when Superman is telling
Donna Troy like Batman who laughs is
gonna wipe out everything on earth the
response to Commissioner Gordon as well
it's just a purge is what it is it's
getting rid of the week and only keeping
those who want to see the truth right
who want to have their eyes open and so
what he basically says is that like what
he needed was an object from the dark
multiverse what he needed is what used
to be the Justice League satellite from
the dark multiverse of the Batman who
lasts and what he'd done here this is
one of the coolest things ever what a
Batman who laughs had done here it's he
had modified the satellite of the
Justice League from his universe that
were we can largely assume it functioned
in the same capacity as the satellite in
the main DC Universe right insofar as
it's a place of monitoring and it's
basically a place to kind of ensure that
things that are going on in the world
can be kept track of not in the sense of
the Justice League's spying on anybody
but in the sense that like if there's
different crises taking place around the
world they can respond effectively right
kind of a safety monitoring device that
what the Batman who laughs are done is
he had modified it in such a way using a
combination of various metals you know
in metal different things like that that
what it does is it essentially can
transform an entire planet right it
could infect an entire world that's the
idea is to bring it here and infect the
entirety of earth all at one time the
issue was that they needed various
people to open the portal a to get the
the portal to a place where it could be
open and this is one of the cool things
about this because it sounds like do you
have these seven characters that have
exist these different these different
things right so you've got magic we're
just covered by uh by Shazam you've got
different characters of played different
roles here and it even references back
to the events of Dark Knights metal it's
like the first step to get in this
portal open was to basically used
Superman to get someone to cross over to
the other side to the Dark multiverse
which is exactly what Superman did right
when Batman was captured by Barbados bit
Superman in the various superheroes used
the Tower of the anti-monitor and the
Phantom Zone projector to get Superman
over to
Dark multiverse that was the first part
of opening the portal right and it's
like all these little steps that have
taken place along the way that seemed
innocuous it seemed kind of like a thing
that was a good idea in the moment that
you never really thought anything about
suddenly become soup Indus Lee important
and it and it's awesome because what is
up happening here is of course Batman
kind of chimes and this is yes I do plan
for everything I'm Batman
of course I plan for everything which
includes somebody's stealing
Commissioner Gordon's old Batman honor
which again is a reference to the new 52
to DC you when when Commissioner Gordon
became Batman after her Bruce Wayne
supposed death during Batman in the game
right so like all these things that have
taken place over DC in the last how many
years this is awesome I've loved this
kind of feeling of cohesiveness right I
love these references these callbacks to
these old stories it's a really really
cool thing and so of course Batman has
to been basically engineered their
escape you know but Batman detonating
this this Batman armor the Commissioner
Gordon used to use and then through of
them sort of getting out there and
saying okay what do we do next
and so what Superman reveals here is
that as part of the fortress of solitude
this makes perfect sense right because
one of the questions is always asked
here is what would happen if somebody
like Lex Luthor infiltrated the fortress
of solitude and try to plunder all of
its secrets and sue man basically
reveals that within the fortress of
solitude is a kind of reactor about a
core reactor and that if something
happens if things go south in the
fortress
you know things basically begin to go
awry then what can happen is is if the
accurate if the reactor itself is ever
in a point of danger then essentially a
release in danger of detonating that
every that everything will basically
lock down in the fortress and the
fortress will sink to the bottom of the
ocean right so nobody gets in and nobody
gets out and that's their idea here
their idea here is okay the the infected
individuals for the most part as they
exist here are locked within the fort's
of Solitude so what we basically do is
we initiate a count now we initiate a a
protocol whereby the entire fortress
gets locked down and basically comes
down here we defeat everybody who's here
we stim the infection and then when
we're done we basically you know
initiate the failsafe that allows the
fortress to come back up and we
basically save the day it's a super
smart idea because what happens here is
is one of the funny things that goes on
is the question is okay like Batman can
you handle your own against Donna Troy
right because we're gonna have to around
face against these guys can you handle
your own against Donna Troy and it's
kind of funny because you know
Superman's like have you ever sparred
with Wonder Woman and Batman's like yeah
man we've sparred and I had bruises for
months
and I know she was holding back it's
cool like it is I love that little thing
it's kind of a cool thing because then
what you do is you pick up with heart a
heart man and you pick up with Donna
Troy this is one of the coolest things
that data that Williamson and DC have
done is that this is not actually
Hawkman from the main DC Universe
this is Hawkman from earth 3 right from
the from the world of the crime
syndicate of America it's cool to see
that some of those guys are still around
I mean not in so far as the ones that
came over during forever evil from the
new 52 but like that's still a universe
that's there there's still various
super-powered beings that are there it's
cool to see that there's there's still
some ties being maintained there because
I love the concept of our three but
Batman showing up here to face off
against Carter Hall as well as face off
against Donna Troy it's kind of a cool
thing right because Carter Hall makes
references like there's no Batman on my
earth there was only an alum an Batman's
like yeah man I crushed him too right
just like I'm gonna destroy you and it's
kind of a cool thing because in the
middle of all this right with this
conflict of playing out the way it is
it's really even two on one in so far as
Donna Troy facing off against like
Batman and you are I'm sorry Batman
facing off against Donna Troy and
Hawkman is a pretty huge task even for
Batman then suddenly you have Supergirl
who comes in to the rescue
right Supergirl is basically like I
overheard what was going on with a 42
solitude so on and so forth and I'm here
for this right now there is a tie-in
they're not really a tie-in I guess it
is kind of a tie-in in the Supergirl
series we can cover if you guys want to
see it but it's basically Supergirl the
infected and it covers like what's going
on with her and how she got here are
different things like that but the idea
here is is it's kind of cool because in
the midst of all that you have a force
Batman being rescued by Supergirl and
then in turn like it's this attempt to
basically you know for Superman to speak
with Jaime Reyes and this is a very very
important thing right because ever since
Jaime Reyes took over the Blue Beetle
from Ted Kord right even before the
events of Flashpoint back during like
Infinite Crisis so on and so forth when
Ted Kord died when you had Tommy ray is
becoming the new Blue Beetle in a lot of
ways highly-rated was kind of rejected
across the board right by like a lot of
fans who looked at him and was just like
he's not Ted Kord oh so I don't care
right I mean that's kind of book fans we
don't like it when things change right
it's just kind of the nature of us as
fans it's always been that way and the
results of that is in a lot of ways
Jaime Reyes was initially rejected was
initially rebuked by by by blue Blue
Beetle fans and the sames harm he was a
character that didn't really know how
his scarab worked he didn't really know
how his powers worked and so I wouldn't
go as far as to say he was looked at as
a liability by the Justice League he
certainly wasn't looked at on the same
level as Ted Kord and so in a lot of
ways
is kind of like what's this guy's place
in the entirety of the DC universe
what's the point of Jaime Reyes as blue
beetle and it's kind of in this thing
that's been holding over his head for
eons right it's just it's always kind of
been that way and so it's an interesting
scenario because the response to
Superman is we don't just see you as a
weapon you're a member of the team you
remember the Justice League right you
know if we've ever done anything that
led you to believe that wasn't the case
then I'm sorry about that it was never
our intention to do that and so it's
cool because it's kind of like hey look
man like you're not as alpha as far out
there and left out in the cold as you
believe you aren't but remember the
nature of the infection of the Batman
who lost is to twist your perspective of
the wall right to twist it inside out
it's like having anxiety right anxiety
and depression it's to twist it inside
out screw up your perspective so that
nothing that you see is actually the way
that it is and then in turn send you
forward out into the world and so it's
kind of interesting because in the
middle of all that the concentration
kind of breaks right you have Donna Troy
who shows up out of nowhere basically
ends up doing Superman which breaks the
kind of connection he had with Jaime
Reyes primary Reyes reverts back into
his Scarab form when the infection takes
hold again at least over the suit anyway
and then in turn you have like this
batter annual is the Saran Batarang
that's thrown and his designer here
Superman only for Supergirl to jump in
the way and catch it and this is a crazy
thing because it's one of these
scenarios where if you were if you're
looking at the story like if you're
reading each each thing as opposed to
skimming then like you would know
exactly what's gonna happen
because one of the things Commissioner
Gordon had said was when he had the
Superman other Superman Batarang he said
this was specifically designed to pierce
that Kryptonian skin of yours and so
assisting what happened with Supergirl
caught it is it pierced her skin and an
infected Supergirl Supergirl is now
infected with the Shazam whoo laughs
toxin in addition to that you have the
arrival of Shazam you have the arrival
of all these various infected heroes who
show up I just want to say here right
because one you've got John Constantine
who's an infected member of the Batman
who lasts family right he's he's one of
the secret six I prefer to think of it
as like the Justice League whoo laughs
which is basically what it is it's like
their own little version of the Justice
League
well you've literally got Shazam Hawkman
John Constantine you've got Donna Troy
you've got Blue Beetle
and you've got Supergirl Supergirl looks
amazing dude let her do her design like
when she's when she's infected dude it
looks awesome man like it looks really
really good I think it's one of the
coolest like like the coolest depictions
of a character like because cheetahs
looks wicked right she almost looks like
a combination between like crush which
is the the daughter I think the daughter
of Lobo and like the Joker right it's a
really cool
constant and I really love the way that
it looks but yes essentially that secret
six is now formed this satellite is
brought in through the portal because
the secret sticks deform and open the
satellite and basically the batman who
laughs is in a position to infect the
entire world with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here two comments
explained make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the Rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop on like and I will catch you
all later peace
[Music]